hi I'm Amelia Clark I'm Henry Goulding
and we are here today with tasty
celebrating our new movie last Christmas
which will be in theaters November 8th
so Henry what are we making we're making
my favorite holiday hot chocolate
truffles yeah so the premise of Lost
Christmas is that you meet a young girl
who's a little bit lost and a little bit
chaotic and she bumps into a young man
who is not any of those things and what
results is a little romance to the
backdrop of this particular young lady
getting herself together in the
wonderful city of London which everybody
finds a romantic especially at
Christmastime so what is it that you do
I sing oh it's amazing
anyway boring boring boring I'm gonna
bored this particular recipe is at a
more american version is the kind of
puritanical hot chocolate sometimes just
won't do but i think the inspiration
behind this recipe being the fact that
hot chocolate is like a hot it's just a
big hug basic mr. sugary beautiful hug
so you can put marshmallows which then
get all gooey and sticky and then you've
got a marshmallow surprise at some point
drink or make it festive and put a candy
cane in it you can crush the candy canes
and roll them around in it so you've got
a minty chocolate treat to give to your
guests yeah more showing the better
[Music]
let's see last Christmas in theaters
November 8th
tis chocolate Eve oh yes